The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
happy to see you again.
Welcome back to 8.03.
So in the beginning
of the class,
I will give you a reminder about
what we discussed last time.
Then the main topic we
are going to discuss today
is about how to
take good photos.
So let's get started.
So last time we have
been working together
trying to understand
how to produce
electromagnetic waves which
can travel to a distance which
is actually very, very far away,
a place which is very, very
far away from the source.
And what we actually figured
out is that in order to do that,
you have to create a kink
in the electric field line
such that you will propagate
and produce radiation.
And this is actually what
we have done last time.
And what we concluded
is that if you
want to produce
electromagnetic waves,
you have to introduce
acceleration
of that charge, such that
you will be able to produce
electromagnetic waves.
And also, we have derived, based
on geometrical arguments, what
would be the magnitude
and the direction
of the radiated electric
field and magnetic field.
And it's actually showing here.
The radiated electric
field is going
to be in the opposite
direction of the projection
of the acceleration, a perp.
The magnitude is
proportional to a perp,
but only evaluated at retarded
time, t prime equal to t
minus r/c, where r is
actually the distance
between the observer and
the radiating charge.
And the reason why we have this
t prime, the retarded time,
is because of the speed of
propagation of information.
So that's actually what
we discussed last time.
And you cannot actually
instantaneously send
the information about the
acceleration of this charge
to somewhere which is
very, very far away.
Therefore, the
acceleration, a perp,
is evaluated at
t prime, which is
t minus r/c, the amount
of time for the speed
of the information traveling
at the speed of light.
And also, the corresponding
magnetic field
can be also evaluated, whether
it's through Maxwell's equation
or using this
formula, this t here.
And finally, we will
be able to evaluate
what would be the pointing
vector, the energy flux
direction or energy flux through
exactly the same equation which
we used before.
That's actually what we
have learned last time.
And today, what
we are going to do
is to learn how to take photos.
So we have prepared ourself.
We know how to produce
electromagnetic waves.
We also know about polarization
of electromagnetic waves.
And we also know how the
polarizer actually works.
So that means we will be able
to make very good photos,
theoretically.
So yeah, that's what
we all care about.
Theoretically, we can actually
make very good photos.
So the first thing which
we would like to discuss
is how to make very good
contrast when you actually
take a photo of the sky.
So as you can see,
the left-hand side
is a photo taken
without a polarizer.
And the right-hand side is the
photo taken with a polarizer.
You can see-- aha!
-- the contrast,
or say the sky is
actually darker,
therefore you can see the
cloud much more clearly.
And also on the same
graph, you can see
there is a photo at the beach.
And you can see exactly
the same phenomenon.
And now we are in the position
to understand what is going on.
So this is actually why
we can use polarizer
to make such a good photo.
So now we know what is actually
happening at the sun, right?
So at the sun,
there are something
which is oscillating--
OK, some kind of
emission from the sun.
And those emissions are not
correlated to each other.
And that produces
unpolarized sunlight.
So if you're looking
to the sun, you
are looking at
unpolarized light.
On the other hand, if you
are looking at the sky,
roughly like 45 or 90 degree--
OK, 45 degree from on the
sun, what is going to happen
is that what you
are actually seeing,
all this light from
the sky, actually,
the sunlight after
scattering between sunlight
and the dust in the air.
So basically, on this
guide, in our air,
there are many, many
little dust, right?
And when light-- as
you shine on this dust,
they change direction,
this so-called scattering.
And those light are
collected by your camera.
The interesting thing is that
if you have a molecule which
is actually here, and you
have some unpolarized sunlight
shining on this molecule,
and it changed direction
by 90 degrees, what is going to
happen is that all the things--
originally you have an
unpolarized sunlight.
Therefore, you have all kinds
of different polarizations,
if you look at the
electromagnetic wave.
However, if you only choose
the light which are scattered
and are going toward this
direction, apparently,
the electromagnetic wave,
or the polarization,
or let's say the direction
of the electric field,
has to be perpendicular to
the direction of propagation.
Therefore, what
is going to happen
is that only this direction,
only the polarization
in this direction, which is
perpendicular to the direction
of propagation will survive.
All the other
components, like the one
which is pointing upward or
pointing downwards, or coming
from the original
sunlight will not survive.
Therefore, what is going
to happen is that when
you do get 45 degrees--
the sky 45 degrees from
the sun, the sunlight
is actually what
kind of sunlight?
Is polarized sunlight.
Therefore, if you
tune your filter
to be aligned with
the polarization,
you will be able to
filter a large amount
of the scattered sunlight.
And that is actually
how this works.
And then you can see that,
indeed, the sky becomes darker
after you apply this polarizer
in front of your camera.
So that's essentially the
first thing which we learn.
The second thing is
that, OK, we also
found that the polarizer
is particularly
usefull for the filtering of the
reflected light on the window.
And of course, we can also
use exactly the same technique
to filter out the
reflected light
from the water for dipole.
And how does this work?
And it turns out that this
actually much more complicated
than what we thought.
And we have to
actually derive this.
And that is actually related
to the electromagnetic wave
propagation inside
the material, and also
related to Brewster's angle.
And that is actually
the main topic
which we are going
to talk about today.
So let's immediately
get started.
So now what we
are interested is,
how does this actually work?
And why is this happening?
And why is the reflected
light become polarized?
So that's the question
we are trying to answer.
So we have talked about
electromagnetic waves
in vacuum.
And we also know how to
generate electromagnetic,
and now we are interested
in electromagnetic wave
in dielectrics.
So we have talked about two
kinds of materials already.
The first one is a
perfect conductor.
And the second one which
we are going to talk about
is a dielectrics material.
In case of perfect
conductor, it costs nothing
to move all the charges
inside this conductor around.
And basically, that will give
you a zero electric field
inside the conductor.
And also, we have a
limited supply of charges.
And therefore, inside this
kind of perfect conductor,
there will be no electric field.
On the other hand, if you have
a dielectrics material, what
is going to happen
is that there are
a lot of charges
inside the material,
but all those
charges are attached
to a specific atom or molecule.
They cannot be moving
freely all over the place.
And that is actually
so-called bound
to the atom or the
location of the molecule.
And that introduces a
little bit of complication.
So this kind of
material, they also
respond to the external magnetic
field or electric field.
For example, in this case,
I have electron cloud which
is around the nuclei in this--
around the positive charge
nucleus in this figure.
And you can see
that before we apply
an external electric field,
it's symmetric around zero.
After we introduce this electric
field, external electric field,
there can be some kind
of polarization produced,
because the electrons
around this nucleus
can be moved slightly, such
that this material is actually
trying to compensate a
little bit the effect
of the external force.
So that is actually
leading to a modification
of the electric field.
But as I mentioned,
you are not going
to cancel all the effect
of the external field.
So how do we understand this?
The idea is the following.
So since this system
is complicated,
you have a free charge.
It could have free charge
as we really kick out
or add some electrons
into this system.
It can have bounce charge.
And if becomes a rather
complicated description.
So the idea is the followiong.
So in order to actually--
for our convenience,
to be similar to what
we have been doing
in vacuum case,
our goal is to
define a field which
is actually with the
material itself subtracted.
In this case, what we can
do is to define a D field,
which is related--
we hope that this is
actually only related
to the free charge
inside the material.
And then we can actually
do all the tricks
which is actually similar
to what we have already
learned from the vacuum--
Maxwell's equation to solve
the problems inside material.
So that's essentially our goal.
In order to do that, we have
to classify the total charge
density, rho, into
two components.
The first component
is the free charge,
which essentially is the
charges which can travel freely
inside the media.
And the bound charge, which
is actually, as I mentioned,
for example, those electrons--
the electron cloud.
And essentially, they are
bound around central location
in the media.
So the idea is the following.
So I can now define a D field.
This D field is a so-called
electric displacement field.
It's defined as epsilon0 times
E field plus a P vector, which
is the polarization vector.
Where this P vector is
defined in the following way--
minus divergence of the
P factor is actually
equal to the bound charge
density, which is rho.
If we have this definition
and we actually continue
and write down the Gauss' law--
and we can see that this is
the Gauss' law, epsilon0--
divergence of E will
be equal to rho.
And we also-- under
our classification,
essentially, there are two
components, rho f and rho p.
The bound charge
and the free charge.
And according to
our definition, this
can be written as rho
f minus delta P vector.
And now what we
can do is that we
can use the definition of the
electric displacement field
and collect all the
terms except the rho
f to the left-hand side.
Then you will conclude
that the divergence of D
will be equal to rho f.
So after this
calculation, you can
see that what we
have achieved is
that we have defined a
field, a displacement field
D, which is totally related to
the effect of the free charge.
In this case, what we
derived is actually
delta D equal to rho f.
And this actually looks pretty
similar to the situation
in vacuum, right?
Because what we actually have is
epsilon0 delta E equal to rho.
And after we actually remove
the contribution of the bound
charge, this becomes
this expression.
Any questions so far?
All right, so this is
actually a purely definition.
And we can also do a very
similar thing to the current.
So the total current, J,
will have the following three
components.
The first component
is the free current,
which is the current related
to free charge moving around
inside this dielectrics method.
There can be contribution
from the bound current.
The bound current is
actually the current
which is only moving around
some specific location.
And finally, the
polarization contribution.
So changing polarization
also introduced a current,
because polarization is
actually defined as q dot times
D, which is the distance
between charges.
And that if I have a changing
polarization, that means also
there are some charges
floating around.
And that actually gives
you the third contribution,
which is, let's say, P.
Once we have classified
the current into three
pieces, and basically, we
can define H field, which is
actually defined as B over mu0,
and the minus M, where M is
a magnetic dipole moment.
And the M field is
actually defined
as the curl of M defined as
the magnitude and direction
of the bound current.
And once we have
finished this definition,
we can actually plug
that into Ampere's law.
Ampere's law, just
a reminder, is
curl B will be equal to
mu0 times J. J is actually
the total current.
Plus a component which is
actually added by Maxwell.
So that actually results in
the electromagnetic waves,
which is epsilon0
partial E partial T.
By using those definitions
and classification,
we can immediately write down--
so if we divide
both sides by mu0,
basically, you conclude
that left-hand side
is 1 over mu0 curl B.
And right-hand side,
you have the contribution
of free charge current.
And you have the contribution
of bound current.
And you have the
third contribution
which is related to a
change in polarization.
And finally, you
have the term which
is added by Maxwell
epsilon 0 partial E
partial T. By using the
definition which we defined
here for the D
displacement field,
and H, which is
actually defined here,
you can see that now we
conclude that the curl of H
will be equal to Jf plus
partial D partial P.
So remember why
we are doing this.
The reason is the following.
We would like to classify the
effect coming from free charge
or free current
inside the material
by subtracting the effect from
the bound current and the bound
charge.
So that's actually what
we have been doing.
Then once we define new fields,
which is actually showing here,
D, which is the displacement
field, is only related to--
which is the field related
to the free charge.
After all, those are
actually just definition.
And the edge field,
the magnetic field
which is actually only related
to the displacement field
and the free
current, we actually
arrive something really,
really similar to the vacuum
case, Maxwell equation.
So that's, essentially,
the excitement.
And you will see that in
8.03, we will use immediately
those conclusions.
And also, we would
limit ourselves
in the discussion of
linear homogeneous
and isotopic materials.
And only work on this
kind of material.
And that is, you would
need to highly simplify
the solution for the
electromagnetic field
or waves inside material.
Any questions so far?
I hope those are just
different issues.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The bound
current is actually
inside the whole
dielectric material.
But of course, you can
have many, many small loops
and they will cancel.
Because if you are looping--
for example, you can have
many, many bound current,
which is actually
surrounding the atom.
But you can see that
all those things--
all the nearby little bound
current will cancel each other.
So therefore, you could
do an integration,
and it becomes a
total bound current,
which is happening
around the surface
of the dielectrics material.
So it depends on what you
mean by how this bound current
actually moves.
So you do have little ones.
And then if you do
integral, then it
becomes a surface bound current.
So if we step these two
conclusions we arrive here,
basically, we can
immediately write down
what would be the Maxwell's
equation in matter.
So now, instead of electric
field and E and the--
E field and the magnetic
field, B field, we also have--
oh, I think there's a
typo there probably.
Ah, there's a typo
in the lower left.
So the lower left
equation, which
is, unfortunately,
propagated to many places,
should be like this.
So the lower left
equation should
be del cross H. That would
be equal to Jf plus partial D
partial t.
So somehow, this is actually
propagated to many places.
So basically, we have
Maxwell's equation
in matter, which is actually
really similar to what
we have in the vacuum case.
So very similar to a discussion
we had in the vacuum case,
what we actually do is to set
the Jf and rho f equal to 0.
If I set the Jf equal
to 0, the last equation
will become curl of
H. And that would be
equal to partial D partial t.
So you can see that this is very
similar to what we had before,
but the problem is that we have
the H field and the D field.
The question is,
how do we actually
relate H field and the D
field with the electric field?
So as we mentioned
before, the D field
is as we defined as epsilon0 D
field plus P, which is actually
the induced polarization
of the material.
And in the case of very
small electric field,
and there is more
magnetic field, and also
a linear and homogeneous
isotropic material,
this induced polarizaiton can
be proportional to the size
of the electric field.
So if this polarization
is proportional
to the electric field,
I can immediately
write down that the
D field is actually
some kind of constant
epsilon times E.
On the other hand, I can
also discuss the H field.
H feel is defined as 1
over mu0 B minus M, which
is the magnetic dipole moment.
In the case of very
small magnetic field
and the linear material,
basically, this and M vector
can be proportional
to the B vector.
Therefore, I can
quickly rewrite this
saying since the M field is
also proportional to the B
field in this linear
material, therefore,
I can rewrite that H will
be equal to B divided by mu.
What is epsilon and the mu?
Epsilon is the permittivity
inside the material.
Permittivity is
actually-- they tell you
the resistance, the resistance
of forming electric field
in some place.
So if you have a
large epsilon, that
means there'll be
large resistance coming
from the material.
So this makes sense, right?
Because that means
you can easily
introduce, or say induce,
larger amount of polarization
in your material.
Then that means this
material is not happy.
It's going to try to cancel
your electrical field.
Therefore, if you
have a large P,
that will give you
a large epsilon.
And therefore,
that means you have
a lot of resistance of forming
electric field, which is still
the E field here.
in matter.
On the other hand,
this mu is actually
permeability of
the, material, which
is the resistance of forming--
it's related to the resistance
of forming a magnetic field.
And basically, these two
quantities are actually
telling you the D
field and the H field
are related to the electric
field and the magnetic field.
So if we assume a linear
relation between D and E,
and elsewhere at
H and B, then we
can actually immediately
rewrite our Maxwell's equation
in matter in the following way.
So you can see that the
resulting Maxwell's equation
in matter considering
a linear material
is really remarkably
similar to what
we have in the vacuum case.
Where is that difference?
Can you see that?
The only difference is in the
last three equations, which
essentially, in the lower
right part of the equation,
instead of mu0 epsilon0, you
now get mu times epsilon.
So what does that mean?
This means that the
speed of the propagation
of the electromagnetic
field is changed.
It's now changed to--
instead of 1 over--
in the vacuum case,
you have c equal to 1
over the square root
of mu0 epsilon0.
Instead of c, we
are going to get
c over n, which n is
the refractive index.
And that is actually equal
to 1 over the square root
of mu and epsilon.
It's as simple as that.
So based on what
we have prepared
in the last few lectures,
we can now immediately make
sense of this equation.
And now that we know that almost
everything is the same, what
is different is that
now we have a difference
speed of propagation,
which is actually
related to the refractive
index we discussed last time.
And now we understand what is
actually this refractive index.
n is actually equal to square
root of mu epsilon divided
by square root of mu0 epsilon0.
Any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What are the
D fields and H field?
Are they just coefficients?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So the D field and
the H field are
the fields which
is actually related
to only the free charge.
So you can see that
now the gradients--
sorry, now the
divergence of D field
is actually only equal to the
density of the free charge.
So basically, in
short, the D field
absorbs the effect of the
bound charge into this field.
And when you try to
actually understand
what would be the field
associated or induced
by the free charge, it
is actually the D field.
But the D field is not the full
story of the electric field.
How is that related
to the electric field
in the exact form?
This is actually defined here.
And from the D
field, you will be
able to evaluate what would
be the corresponding E field.
And in the linear
material, there's
a spatial relation between
D field and the E field,
because the induced
polarization is
proportional to electric field
in the linear material, which
is a special case.
And in that sense, D field
is proportional to E field.
And this factor is
actually so-called epsilon,
which is permittivity
of the material.
Describing how large
is the resistance
of forming an electric
field inside a material.
OK?
Is that clear?
OK, good.
And the H field is
similar argument.
All right, so now
we have made sense
of the electric field
and magnetic field
and the Maxwell's
equations in matter.
And in 8.03, we will only
discuss linear material.
You can imagine
that the relation
between the polarization and
the external electric field
can be very complicated.
So for example, it
depends on how large
is the wavelengths of
the external force.
So if you have very slowly
varying electric field,
you can imagine
that you will not
be able to create a
polarization, which
is the inner electron
ground level.
Because the variation of the
electric field is too slow.
But instead, you will be able to
excite the polarization related
to ions inside this material,
or inside the plasma.
So on the other hand, if
you have a very, very fast
oscillating electric
field, then you
will be able to
measure the shift
or create a polarization
which is actually
related to the displacement of
the electron cloud inside that.
So it really depends
on many, many factors.
But what we have been
discussing here and elsewhere
is highly idealized
linear materials.
And a lot of interesting
things to explore in the future
beyond 8.03.
So once we have
this relation, we
will be able to get
Maxwell's equation in matter.
And we would like to
understand, just to remind you,
why are we doing this?
So we have a physical question.
We have a question
about a phenomenon
which we see in this slide.
So when we use the
polarizer, very strange,
you will be able to filter
out the reflected light
from the sun and through--
when the sunlight hit the
window and got reflected,
this kind of contribution can be
filtered out almost completely
by polarizer.
So that means the
reflected light is somehow
also polarized.
And then why is that
the case is the question
we were trying to answer here.
So therefore, what I
am going to do is to,
again, take a look at the
boundary between two materials.
The one side is actually in the
air, which we call it number 1.
And the other side is
actually the glass, which
I call it material number 2.
And now I have, again,
some incident prime wave,
which is coming from the sun.
And actually, this incident
prime wave actually
goes into this surface which
is the boundary between air
and glass in the discussion
which I am trying to get into.
I assume that this glass
is actually very wide.
It's actually fielding
the whole universe.
Therefore, this is actually
just a simple plane,
a boundary which
actually divides
our world into air and glass.
We know from the discussion
of previous lecture,
so there must be
a reflected light
and there must be
transmission into the glass.
Because this is actually the
general property of waves.
So OK, it has nothing to do
with electromagnetic wave yet,
but if you have wave, and
you have an incident wave,
you are going to
have a reflected wave
and the transmitted wave.
We learned from the two
laws of geometrical optics,
we know that the
incident angle, theta i,
will be equal to the
reflective angle, theta r,
with respect to the normal
direction of this surface.
And we also know
that the KI, which
is the wave number of
vector of the incident wave,
KR, which is the wave
number vector, the K vector,
of the reflected
wave, and the K vector
for the transmitting wave, KT.
And this is actually theta T.
These three K vectors
must have a fixed relation
so that the electromagnetic
field, or say all those three
wave equations-- the
sum of these three wave
equations in the left-hand
side world and right-hand side
world, they are
connected to each other.
They don't break.
There's no discontinuity between
the sum of the left-hand side
plane waves and the sum of the
right-hand side plane wave.
So that means it has
to obey Snell's law.
And there will be a fixed--
the size of the
projection of the K
vector onto the direction of
this surface will be the same.
Otherwise, you will have
different wavelengths
in the vertical direction.
Then the electromagnetic
wave will break, right?
Because you can-- as you
always change your position
when evaluating the total
contribution of the incident,
reflected, and
transmitted waves.
So once we have all this
information in hand,
we can actually write
down the expression
for the incident wave,
EI, which is actually
a function of r and t.
And of course, I would like
to define my coordinate system
first.
So this is the x direction.
And this is y direction.
OK, sorry.
This is usually the
z direction actually.
The x direction is going up.
y direction is actually
pointing to you.
And the z direction is
pointing to the right-hand side
of the board.
And this is actually at z
equal to 0, this interface
between glass and air.
And now I can
actually write down
what will be the incident
wave electric field.
And that is actually equal
to E0I, which is a vector,
tell you about the polarization
of the incident wave.
Cosine-- by now this should
look pretty familiar to you now.
This is actually
just a KI dot r,
which describes the
direction of the propagation.
Minus omega t.
So this is actually
describing the incident wave,
which I call it EI.
And I will assume
that since I know
what would be incident wave,
that E0I is a known quantity.
So I say that this is
actually a known quantity.
So now I can also
do the same thing
and write down what would
be the reflected wave.
ER as a function of r and t.
And this will be,
very similarly,
E0R, which is
actually telling you
the magnitude and
the polarization
of the reflected wave, cosine
KR dot r minus omega t.
All right, and finally,
you have the ET, which
is a function of r and t again.
And this will be E0T cosine
KT times r minus omega t.
Of course, they will have three
electric fields, therefore,
you must have three what field?
AUDIENCE: Magnetic.
PROFESSOR: Magnetic field, yes.
So you must have the
corresponding magnetic field.
So you, for example, BI.
It's a function of r and t.
Will be equal to
1 over V1, which
is the velocity in the air.
V1 is actually equal to c.
KI hat, the direction of
the propagation cross--
OK, so I'm not going to
write down BR and BT,
because this is actually
a very similar expression
as the corresponding associated
magnetic field for the incident
wave.
All right, so basically,
we have actually
translated the
physical situation
into mathematics using the
coordinate system, which
we defined here.
So one thing which is
actually very interesting
is that we have solved
half of the question
in the previous lecture.
So in the previous
lecture when we discussed
two-dimensional or
three-dimensional waves,
we have concluded that
if you have a wave,
and it's continuous at
the surface, z equal to 0,
you can immediately conclude
that basically KI dot
r will be equal to KR dot r.
This will be equal to KT dot r.
This is the first thing
which we actually conclude.
That actually leads to what?
What law?
Snell's law.
Yes, very good.
If this expression doesn't
hold, then your left-hand side
and right-hand side total
electric field doesn't match
at the surface of z equal to 0.
The second thing
which we learned
is that theta I will be
equal to theta R. OK,
so basically, that's
actually what we have learned
from the previous lecture.
Therefore, this match in between
left-hand side electric field
and right-hand side electric
field becomes much simpler.
Since that they are actually
just some E0 times cosine,
a functional formula
showing here.
Since these three products
are identical, therefore,
what is going to happen is
that the location dependence
and the time dependence of this
relation completely cancels.
Because you just have
the individual vector,
E0I, E0R, E0T, multiplied
by a cosine function which
is identical for
those three incident
transmitted and the
reflected waves.
Therefore, in the discussion
of this kind of thing,
you can actually ignore
the location dependence
and the time dependence,
since they always cancel.
So that's actually a pretty
useful thing to have.
And don't forget what
is our goal, right?
So our goal is to know, OK,
so if I have a given incident
prime wave, what would be the
resulting reflected wave, what
would be the resulting
transmitted wave?
And I would like to tell
you the conclusion first.
The relation between
the reflected wave,
transmitted wave,
and incident wave
depends on the
Maxwell simulation.
You can see that this
relation have nothing
to do with Maxwell's
equation so far.
It's actually really related
to the wave description
we are using.
And also, the the match in
between the left-hand side
and right-hand
side wave equation.
So you know, now we have learned
this is actually only related
to a generic property
wave equation.
So now we need to get the help
from the Maxwell's equation
in matter so that
I can make sense
about the relation between
E0R, E0T with respect
to what is given, E0I.
So how do we do that?
So the first thing
which I would like to do
is that, as you see from here,
I divided the whole universe
into two parts.
The left-hand side wall,
I call it 1, is air.
The right-hand side wall is
glass, which is I call it 2.
Therefore, I can
now calculate what
will be the sum of the electric
field in the world number 1,
which is actually
defined as E0I plus E0R.
So here you can see that I
already dropped the cosine,
because they always cancel.
Therefore, I just write down
E0I and E0R without the cosine.
And of course, I
can also calculate
what will be the total electric
field in the right-hand side
world, inside the glass.
And that is actually
equal to E0T.
The question is how
to relate E1 and E2.
And for that, as I
mentioned, I need
the help of Maxwell's
equation in matter.
How do we actually do that?
So what we could
do is that since we
have Maxwell's equation, the
first thing which we can do
is that we can look at the
perpendicular direction.
The perpendicular direction
means the projection
of the electric field in
the perpendicular direction
to the surface.
That's what I mean by
perpendicular direction.
So for that, I can make use of
the first Maxwell's equation
in matter, which is actually
del dot D equal to 0.
We are considering the case
without any free charge.
So that means I have Gauss' law,
which is actually D times da.
I do a surface integral.
And that will be equal to 0.
So this means that I can have
a pillbox again, like this.
I arrange this
pillbox like this.
And this is actually
the surface.
The size of one
side perpendicular
to the direction of the surface
is actually called D here.
And I have this box here.
And the left-hand side, D1, will
be equal to epsilon1 E perp--
D1 perp, actually, will be
equal to epsilon1 E perp 1.
Epsilon1 is the permittivity
of the material number
1, which is actually equal
to epsilon0 in this case,
because it is actually air.
And the right-hand
side, you have D perp 2.
This is actually equal
to epsilon2 E perp 2.
So now I have figured
out what would
be the field going into
this pillbox and the field
going out of this pillbox.
What I can do now
is the following.
I can now shrink the size of
the pillbox, having d goes to 0.
And it becomes smaller,
smaller, and smaller.
So what is going to happen is
that when this d goes to 0,
this surface integral
will go to what?
Go to also 0.
Therefore, I can immediately
conclude that epsilon1 E perp
1--
OK, so when I have
this d goes to 0,
the contribution from
the side goes to 0.
I know already the sum of all
the contribution of the surface
integral will be
equal to 0, but I
don't know what is the
contribution from the side.
But if I have that d goes to
0, then the area of the four--
1, 2, 3, 4--
sides, it's actually
going to go to 0.
Therefore, you have
zero contribution
to this surface integral.
Therefore, I can conclude
that epsilon1 E perp 1
will be equal to epsilon2 E perp
2, based on this discussion.
All right, any questions so far?
I hope everybody is following.
Now, I can also use
the third equation,
which is actually del cross E--
the fourth equation--
which is actually the--
oh, sorry for that.
I can actually use
the second equation,
which is the curl of E would
be equal to minus partial B
partial t.
So that means I can have
an integral E dot dl.
And that is going to be equal
to minus d dt, B dot dx.
All right, so if I
used the third equation
in Maxwell's
equation, basically, I
have an integral over a loop,
over some closed surface,
and that would be equal
to minus d dt, B dot--
this the actually the integral
looking at the flux going
through this little area.
So what I can do
is now I, again,
zoom in to the surface which
connects the two worlds.
And I can now define a
loop which is like this.
With width equal to d.
And there can be a contribution
from the magnetic field
in the right-hand side integral
contributing to this equation.
I can immediately write
down the left-hand side
will be E parallel 1.
Why?
Because right now
we are actually
looking at the component of
the electric field parallel
to the surface.
And I can also immediately
write down the right-hand side
of this loop integral.
You are going to
have E parallel 2.
And now I can do
exactly the same trick,
having this d goes to 0.
The effect of this
is the following.
So if I have this
rectangular loop,
and now if I have
this side d goes to 0,
that means you will have no area
to integrate the flux for the B
field.
So therefore, if I have d goes
to 0, this will be equal--
this also goes to 0.
Therefore, I can
immediately conclude
that this means that
E parallel 1 will
have to be equal to E parallel
2, based on this discussion.
So this means that,
well, we can immediately
conclude that first
of all, in order
to figure out the relation
between the incident wave,
reflected wave, and
transmitted wave,
we need the help not only
from the general property
of the wave equation, and
also some matching boundary
conditions, we also
need the help to provide
additional boundary
conditions to relay
the electric field
in the left-hand side
and right-hand side.
That is actually coming from
our understanding of Maxwell's
equation in matter.
So you can see that
the second two boundary
conditions, epsilon1 E
perp 1, perpendicular,
will be equal to epsilon2
E 2 perpendicular.
And that's essentially related
to this surface integral D.
And the second
condition which tells
us, will relate the field
in the parallel direction
is actually also coming
from Maxwell's' equation.
And we conclude that E
parallel in the left-hand side
will be equal to E parallel
in the right-hand side.
So we are almost there
to solve the puzzle.
So now what I have to
do is the following.
So now I would like
to assume that we
have some kind of
polarization for the incident
and the transmitted waves.
So I assume that
the polarization,
it should be the following.
The polarization is
actually in parallel.
I assume that the polarization
is in parallel to the xz plane.
So that's actually
my assumption.
So now I introduce
a new assumption,
which is that the
incident wave is actually
having a polarization.
The electric field is actually
oscillating up and down
in this direction, which
is actually parallel
to the xz plane.
So I can write down the
corresponding E0R vector.
And finally-- and this will be
perpendicular to the direction
of propagation.
And finally, I will be
able to also write down
what will be the
corresponding polarization
for the transmitted wave,
which is also, again,
perpendicular to the
direction of propagation
So therefore I can now make use
of the boundary condition one
and boundary condition
two to actually figure out
what would be the relation
between E0I, E0R, and E0T.
The first thing
which we consider
is to consider the
perpendicular direction.
For equation number
one, I will be
able to conclude that epsilon1
minus E0I sine theta I.
So basically, that is
actually the contribution
from the first vector, E0I.
You can see that now I am
trying to project everything
to the direction
perpendicular to the surface.
And you can see that
I have a minus sign.
And that this angle
is actually theta.
So therefore, I have--
So this angle is actually what?
This angle is actually
I minus theta.
So therefore, I have
the cosine theta I.
And I have this minus
sign, because it's
pointing to the left-hand
side of the board.
So that's actually
the contribution
of the incident wave.
And I have a second
term, which is
the contribution of the
reflected wave, E0R sine theta
I. So E0I, E0R with all vector
is actually just the length
of the vector in my definition.
And based on the first
boundary condition,
I have the left-hand
side looks like this.
On the right-hand side, I will
have minus epsilon2 E0T sine
theta T.
Again, I am looking at the
projection of this E0T vector
in the direction
which is actually
perpendicular to the surface.
So that's the first
expression I can get.
And then from the expression
number two, I can now--
taking the projection, which
is parallel to the surface,
so now this is actually
the parallel direction.
And basically, what
I'm going to get
is E0I cosine theta I
plus E0R cosine theta I--
oh sorry, theta R. Theta R
is actually equal to theta I,
so therefore, I actually
replaced that by the I already.
And that will be equal to E0T
cosine theta T. Any questions
so Far so I was pretty fast.
So here, I already
immediately write down
this is actually theta R.
Theta R is equal to theta I,
so therefore, I already
replaced that by theta I.
Do you have any questions?
So the painful period is going
to end in like 3 minutes, OK?
So we are almost there.
And look what we
have been doing.
We basically figured out
the boundary condition
from Maxwell's equation.
Then we are plugging in that.
So we assume that the
polarization is actually
parallel on the
plane of xz plane.
And now we are actually
just evaluating
the parallel component and
the perpendicular component.
So that's actually
what we've got.
The goal, as a reminder,
is to write E0R and E0T
in terms of the known
part, which is the E0I.
I would like to
relate these three--
the magnitude of
these three vectors.
So from equation number one,
I can actually rewrite that.
Basically, I can
actually conclude
that I can divide everything
by epsilon1 sine theta I.
So what I'm going to
get is E0I minus E0R.
And this will be equal
to epsilon2 sine theta
T divided by epsilon1 sine theta
R. And this is actually E0T.
So basically, I'm
dividing everything
by minus epsilon1 sine theta I.
Then basically, what
you are going to get
is this expression.
And this actually can be related
to another expression, which
is epsilon2 n1 divided
by epsilon1 n2.
Because I can use Snell's law.
n1 sine theta I will be equal
to n2 sine theta T. Therefore,
I can replace this ratio of
sine angle by refractive index.
Everybody's following?
OK, very good.
And this will be
multiplied by E0T.
I can now define this.
This is actually
defined as theta E0T
to make our life easier.
The same thing can be done
for the second expression.
What I'm going to
get is E0I plus E0R.
Basically, what I'm doing
is to divide everything
by cosine theta I. So
what is going to happen
is that you are going to
get cosine theta T divided
by cosine theta I E0T.
And that is actually
defined as alpha E0T.
So alpha is defined as cosine
theta T divided by cosine
theta I.
Therefore, I can
already immediately,
based on these two expressions,
to solve what would be the E0R.
I can write down the solution.
So basically, you can
actually quickly derive
what would be the E0R.
And that is actually going to
be my alpha minus beta divided
by alpha plus beta, E0I.
And you can also solve based
on these two equations what
would be the E0T.
And now we will
conclude that this
will be equal to 2 divided
by alpha plus beta, E0I.
So this means that the
refractive index will
be equal to alpha minus beta.
Sorry, refraction
coefficient will
be equal to alpha minus beta
divided by alpha plus beta.
And the transmission
coefficient is actually
2 over alpha plus beta.
So we will take maybe a
three minute break for you
to be able to ask
some questions.
But you can see that we
have solved the relation
between E0I, E0R, and E0T.
And what we have to do
in the rest of the time
is to enjoy what we
actually already derived,
and what actually that
means, after the break.
So we come back at 45.
OK, so very good.
So we have survived this.
And now it's time to
enjoy what we have
learned from this equation.
All right, so welcome
back everybody.
So we have actually
saw what would
be the refraction coefficient
and the transmission
coefficient tau.
And those are the functions
of alpha and beta.
So that's considered three
different interesting cases.
So if I have normal incidence.
And that means alpha
will be equal to cosine
theta T divided by cosine theta
I. This is the definition.
If I have no more
incidence, that
means both theta T,
theta I, and theta R
will be equal to 90 degrees.
And in this case, basically,
you will have the same cosine
theta--
I mean cosine I. Theta
T and cosine theta I.
And that means your alpha will
be equal to 1 in this case.
So in normal material, mu1
is roughly equal to mu2
and roughly equal to mu0.
So therefore, this means
that if mu1, mu2, and mu0
are very close to each
other, then actually,
the refractive index based
on that equation which
is showing there, will
be basically, roughly
equal to square root of
epsilon divided by epsilon0.
So therefore, beta would be
equal to epsilon2 divided
by epsilon1, n1 divided by n2.
This is actually the definition.
And this will be
basically equal to--
since this is actually
proportional to epsilon2
divided by epsilon1.
And n is actually proportional
to epsilon, square root
of epsilon.
Therefore, you can
conclude that this actually
will be equal to n2 squared
divided by n1 squared,
n1 divided by n2.
And that will give
you n2 divided by n1.
You can actually cancel one
of the n2 and one of the n1.
So beta will be equal
to n2 divided by n1.
And therefore, you
can conclude that R
will be a function just related
to the refractive index, which
means that you are going to get
n1 minus n2 divided by n1 plus
n2.
Which means that the
amount of reflected light
is related to the difference
in the refractive index.
Then the amount of
the transmitted light
will be equal two n1
divided by n1 plus n2.
So what does that mean?
This means that if you have some
material which is essentially
like diamond, diamond have an
n2 equal to something like 2.6,
that means a lot of
light will get reflected,
even if you have
no more incidence.
So that's actually why the
diamonds are so beautiful,
because a lot of light, pretty
bright, and a lot of things
are actually reflected.
The transmitted fraction
is actually pretty small.
I can also assume that there
can be a grazing incidence.
That happens-- this
means that I am
going to have theta I. This
theta I should be here.
This theta I is going to
be roughly 90 degrees.
In the case of no
more incidence, theta
I should be equal to zero.
Maybe I misspoke
in the beginning.
So what does that mean?
This means that alpha will
go to infinity, because theta
I is going to 90 degrees.
Therefore, you have
R roughly equal
to 1, because R is
actually alpha minus beta
divided by alpha plus beta.
If alpha goes to infinity,
then R will go to 1.
And the tau will be--
actually, roughly goes to 0.
So that means if you
have a grazing incidence,
then basically, most of
the light are reflected.
So that's actually
why when we see,
for example, reflected light
from the sun, which is actually
on the road, we see that a
lot of light are reflected.
When we see a lake which is
actually very far away from me
and the sun in front of it,
you see a huge amount of lite
got reflected and
going to your eyes.
Looks really bright.
So finally, there is a
very interesting angle,
which is actually
considering a situation when
alpha is equal to beta.
This is a very
interesting angle,
theta B. If we choose
this theta B such
that alpha is equal to beta,
what is going to happen?
Somebody can tell me.
If I make--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Exactly, right?
So if you choose an angle such
that alpha is equal to beta,
then R will be equal to 0.
There will be no reflection.
And everything goes
through the material.
So that is actually
so-called Brewster's angle.
And this happens when theta B--
which theta B is actually
the incident angle--
plus theta T is
equal to pi over 2.
There's a proof of this
Brewster's angle in the lecture
notes.
But we are kind of
running out of time.
But the conclusion
is that you will
need to have theta B, which
is actually equal to theta I,
the incident angle, plus the
transmission light angle,
theta D. If that is
equal to 90 degrees,
then you can make
alpha equal to 0.
And what is going to
happen is that there
will be no reflected light.
So when this happens,
when the reflected light
and the transmitted light
have an angle of 90 degrees,
then the amplitude goes to 0.
This is actually a very
interesting property
and it only works for
electromagnetic waves,
because this is actually
coming from, really,
the effect of
Maxwell's equation.
So now what I'm going to
say is that basically, we
look at this demonstration.
So if we have an incident light,
and the transmitted light.
Originally, the incident
light is unpolarized.
So you can have all kinds
of different polarization.
So we can become
post polarization
into a component which
is actually pointing
to you, which is the dot.
And the component,
which is actually
the parallel to my slide, which
is actually what we have been
working on, that situation.
So what is going to happen
is that the component which
is pointing you
is actually never
gets suppressed, because
there will be no perpendicular
component.
So therefore, even if
you add Brewster's angle,
it should get reflected.
On the other hand,
all the components
which essentially
heavy polarization
parallel to this
slide is eliminated
because of this relation.
So that means the reflected
light will be highly polarized.
Do you believe me?
Maybe not.
We can do an experiment
and really show you
that's the case.
So we are almost there.
So now I need to turn off
the light and hide the image.
And you can see that there
is a setup here which
I produce unpolarized light.
And there's a glass
here, which actually I
reflect the unpolarized light.
So now you can see that if
I have some random angle,
and I have a polarizer here--
I hope you can see it--
you can see that the polarizer
cannot eliminate all the light.
So basically, no matter
what kind of direction,
it will not be able to eliminate
all the reflected light.
This means there's some
mixture of all kinds
of different polarization.
But now, if I change the
direction to Brewster's angle,
it's roughly here, so you
can see that now, indeed,
I can actually eliminate
all the contribution
of the reflected light.
Because the reflected
light is highly polarized.
As you can see from the
slide, all the component
which is actually
parallel to the slides
is actually eliminated
due to Brewster's angle.
And that produces
a polarized light.
And that can be filtered
out by the polarizer.
So coming back to the
question which we had before,
so why can we take
such a good photo?
That is because of
Brewster's angle.
So once the sunlight gets
reflected by the window,
it becomes linearly polarized,
and therefore, you can actually
filter out the majority
of the contribution
by using polarization filter.
OK, thank you very much.
And I hope you enjoyed
the lecture today.
And hope this will improve
your technique, your skill,
for taking good photos.
If you have any questions,
please let me know.
Hello, everybody.
So today I'm going to show you
a demonstration of Brewster's
angle.
So during the class,
we were discussing
about how to make
very good photos, how
to use polarizer to filter
out the reflected light
from the sun.
Usually, when you actually
take a photo of water or a car,
there are refracted light
from the sun on the window
or on the water.
And then you can actually use
polarizer to filter them out.
And that has to do
with the property
of the electromagnetic wave
and the Brewster's angle.
So here I have an
experimental setup here,
which consists of
three components.
The first component is a
polarized light source.
And it meets unpolarized light.
And those light are getting
refracted by glass here.
And the unrefracted
light will actually
be shown on the screen
as a spot there.
So at first, if I have my
glass, which essentially--
the position of the
glass is in a way such
that it's actually not
on Brewster's angle.
And now I can actually check
if this light is actually
polarized by using
a polarizer here.
And if I put this polarizer
between the screen
and the glass, you
can see that, huh,
as a function of the angle which
I am rotating this polarizer,
you can see that no angle can
actually completely eliminate
the reflected light.
So that means that the
reflected light is actually not
perfectly polarized.
But on the other hand, you can
also see that in some angles,
you can actually significantly
lower the intensity.
And that, essentially, is
also pretty good for photo
taking, because that means
all the reflected light,
although now the
angle is actually not
at Brewster's angle, you
still have the reflected light
slightly polarized.
So that actually your polarizer
in front of the camera
will still do some work.
Now what I'm going to do is
to change the angle so that it
matches with Brewster's angle.
So now you can see
that if I insert
a polarizer between the
glass and the screen,
you can see that at some
angle, for example, now
we can actually filter out
or completely eliminate
the spot on the screen.
So that means at
Brewster's angle,
basically, the reflected
light is actually
completely polarized,
as we actually
predicted from the lecture.
And the reason is the following.
There's only one direction
of the polarized light
from the unpolarized
source can get reflected
due to the boundary condition
of the electromagnetic wave.
And therefore, we see
this very unique phenomena
which we can only see in
electromagnetic waves.